[Musik]
herzlich willkommen jaffa sie zu hause
einen hund haben oder eine katze oder
ein goldfisch dann haben sie sich
bestimmt schon gefragt was ihr tier wohl
denkt über sie über die welt und über
sich selbst
und ob das tier überhaupt denkt so ganz
ohne sprache oder haben tiere eine
sprache nur eine ganz andere
über all das werde ich heute reden und
zwar mit einem ganz besonders klugen
tier nämlich mit einem menschen ja sogar
mit einem philosophie-professor herzlich
willkommen haben sie ihren blog
herzlichen dank für die einladung ja ist
der mensch denn wirklich das klügste
tier auf erden oder machen wir uns
selbst etwas vor ja wir sind das glück
hier auf erden ok und zwar unabhängig
davon wie man jetzt klugheit auffasst
ob man das als bloße intelligenz auf
fast oder als einsicht in die kausalen
zusammenhänge oder als vernunft die
fähigkeit über unsere ziele nachzudenken
in allen drei sparten stechen wir die
tiere klar aus gibt es nicht auch die
fähigkeit wo die tiere uns überlegen
sind das gibts doch sicherlich natürlich
gibt es körperliche fähigkeiten in denen
sie uns überlegen sind
es gibt auch bestimmte mentale
fähigkeiten in denen sie besser
abschneiden möchte muss er bestimmte
affenarten können bei ganz einfachen
computerspielen wo sie zum beispiel
zahlen in einer reihenfolge abtasten
müssen schneller agieren als wir also
ich erkenne schneller dass die vier da
oben ist bum 567 natürlich erst nachdem
man ihn diese zahlen ganz mühevoll
beigebracht hat was würden sie denn
sagen ist als das was den menschen
ausmacht und in unterscheidet von allen
anderen tieren was ganz wichtig ist wir
sollten den blick auf menschliche
gemeinschaften werfen und die mit
tierischen gemeinschaften vergleichen
und da werden wir feststellen dass
menschlich gemeinschaften einzigartig
sind also schauen sie sich mal nur hier
um ja was wir hier veranstalten das ist
nun wirklich also eine liga über allem
was wir auch bei den komplexesten tier
gemeinschaften finden und ich denke dass
wir eine einmalige kombination von
fähigkeiten aufweisen wir haben eine
einsicht in kausale zusammenhänge wir
haben also kausale zusammenhängen heißt
zum beispiel keine ahnung wenn ich
dieses glas erfahrungen lasse dann geht
es kaputt und das ist deswegen weil es
fallen gelassen habe als ursache
wirkungs zusammenhänge genau also wir
lernen nicht nur durch versuch und
irrtum sondern wir gewinnen auch
einsichten in tieferen zusammenhänge
kann ich das vielleicht mal ein beispiel
es gibt die dgap
da haben sie einen durchsichtigen
plastik zylinder der ist an beiden enden
verschlossen aber nach unten gibt es
eine öffnung
jetzt wurde am einen ende seit wir hier
eine art muss platziert wenn sie das
einem kapuzineräffchen geben ja dann
schüttet der wild hin und her bis dann
die die erdnuss zufällig rausfällt wenn
er das mal erkannt hat dann hat er
gelernt wie das geht
während schimpansen und wir wir schauen
uns die anordnung einmal an
schwupp und die sache ist sprichwörtlich
gegessen
das heißt wir können vorher sehen weil
wir eine einsicht haben in kausale
zusammenhänge was passieren wird ohne es
vorher schon langwierig aus zu aber auch
ein vorstellungsvermögen imagination was
wir uns das im kopf schon vorstellen was
passiert mit dieser erdnuss und dann
machen wir das ist richtig also
vorhersage beinhaltet immer auch das
vorstellen von verschiedenen optionen
und verschiedenen möglichkeiten wie sich
eine sache entwickeln kann
jetzt wissen ja philosoph haben sich
lange intensiv mit der menschlichen
denkens auseinandergesetzt mit der
sprache mit dem menschlichen bewusstsein
wird seit einigen jahren
intensiv mit dem denken und dem
bewusstsein von tieren wie kommen sie
als philosoph dazu über den geist der
tiere zu forschen ja viele
zuschauerinnen werden erwarten dass das
durch eine persönliche beziehung
geschehen ist also durch eine beziehung
zu haustieren
dem ist aber nicht so wir hatten zwar
als kinder die handelsüblichen hamster
die haben wir dann aber mit den besten
absichten durch fütterung von schokolade
vergiftet wir können daraufhin haben
unsere eltern beschlossen dass hier wird
zu wertvoll sind um auf dem altar
unserer aufmerksamkeiten geopfert zu
werden
von daher ist mein zugang er
intellektuell nämlich was war die frage
die sie am ursprung umgetrieben hat also
zunächst soll ich sagen dass ich
einerseits an der frage interessiert bin
weil ich schon immer mich für biologie
begeistert habe und dieses interesse an
evolutionstheorie und
verhaltensforschung ist mir geblieben
andererseits besteht natürlich der
zugang durch die philosophie
also ich bin innerhalb der analytischen
philosophie sozialisiert worden
besonders durch die auseinandersetzung
mit wittgenstein und in dieser reichen
philosophen ludwig wittgenstein er wolle
und in dieser tradition kommt der
sprache eine ganz besondere bedeutung zu
nicht nur zeichnet sie uns menschen aus
sondern sie gilt als voraussetzung des
denkens von daher habe ich ursprünglich
dazu geneigt tieren allenfalls ganz
einfache mentale fähigkeiten zu zu
schreiben und zu bestreiten dass sie
denken können
als ich dann aber ein buch über den
amerikanischen philosophen download
davidson geschrieben habe der genau
diese meinung ganz ausführlich vertritt
da haben wir seine argumente einfach
nicht eingeleuchtet und von daher bin
ich dann zu der allgemeinen frage
gekommen haben tiere überhaupt einen
geist und wie muss man überhaupt
begriffe wie geist denken wahrnehmen
bewusstsein fassen nehmen wir mal so
einen ganz konkreten prüfstein ein ganz
seltsames tier auf das ich gestoßen bin
in der vorbereitung
bald bereitung auf diese sendung nämlich
kraken ich habe auf netflix die
dokumentation gesehen mein lehrer der
krake und war verblüfft wie intelligent
diese wesen sind obwohl sie uns
genetischen körperlich so fremd sind
also sie können sich tarnen sie können
dingen nachmachen
sie können sich sogar verkleiden ihre
farbe ist in sekundenschnelle ändern und
das nervensystem verteilt sich über den
ganzen körper wie ein riesiges gehirn
man fragt sich unwillkürlich was geht in
so einen kraken vor was denkt der was
fühlt kann man das wissen ja ich war
auch von diesem film sehr beeindruckt er
zeigt dass kraken nicht nur hoch
intelligent sind sondern auch neugierig
die wollen etwas lernen
und obwohl sie eigentlich eher solitäre
lebewesen sind sind sie auch in der lage
mit menschen zu interagieren
die frage was in einem kraken vor sich
geht die halte ich in gewisser weise für
irreführend wir neigen dazu wenn wir vom
intelligenten verhalten von tieren
beeindruckt sind ihnen so eine
sprechblase anzudichten wie im comic
strip und dann kommen wir sehr in
verlegenheit wenn es darum geht wie
wollen wir jetzt diese sprechblase
ausfüllen ja sprachliche sätze scheinen
nicht tauglich bilder scheinen auch
nicht tauglich bei lebewesen die ganz
anders zum beispiel sehen als wir und
ich denke wir sollten diese ganze
sprechblasen konzept denkt blase
entschuldigung denkt blasen konzeption
aufgeben ja und anstatt zu fragen was
geht jetzt in dieser denkt blase vor
sich während sich das tier intelligent
verhalf erhält sollten wir vielmehr
fragen was kann das tier in welchen
situationen reagiert wie und wir dürfen
das durchaus mit mentalist ischen
ausdrücken beschreiben ja also die krake
denkt dass sie wieder ins wasser zurück
muss und der hai auf sie warte zb sie
versucht den hai zu täuschen etc
aber wir sollten nicht denken dass da
unbedingt ein begleittext
er im geist stattfinden muss das ist bei
uns auch nicht der fall
aber wir erleben doch bewusst etwas wir
haben angst vor etwas oder wir vermuten
etwas wir wünschen uns etwas und so und
das sind doch dinge die hier im geist
ablaufen während dem wir uns in der welt
bewegen und und verkaufen ich würde ganz
einfach sagen ja wir haben angst wir
vermuten etwas wir wünschen etwas aber
dieses wünschen besteht nicht unbedingt
darin dass parallel zu unserem verhalten
ein innerer text abläuft also ich werde
völlig aufgeschmissen wenn ich jetzt in
diesem interview
alles was ich sage vorher aus meiner
inneren denkt blase ablesen müsste und
ihnen dann präsentieren
so geht das nicht dass wir machen uns
das was wir denken eigentlich erst im
nachhinein über sprache bewusst
dann dachte ich das ist nun aber mal
eine schräge frage aber das ist in dem
moment in dem ich auf diese frage
vielleicht etwas zurückhalten oder
packard reagiert habe nichts was mir
bewusst durch den kopf geschossen wäre
aber es gibt doch auch diese momente wo
wir jetzt sozusagen gedankenversunken
etwas vor unserem inneren geist sprechen
oder so diese innere stimme bei uns
menschen zu malen das gibt es sicherlich
aber das ist doch eher die ich würde
fast sagen schon eher die ausnahme und
das ist dann sozusagen das top end des
denkens ja also wenn ich mir überlege
wie genau formuliere ich jetzt dieses
argument für die schlussfolgerung dass
tiere denken können weil sie wahrnehmen
können dann überlege ich mir das ganz
genau wobei bei mir jedenfalls dass oft
auch auf dem papier oder auch über die
tastatur geschieht aber es scheint ein
starkes bedürfnis zu sein zumindest von
mir zu wissen wie es sich anfühlt so ein
anderes wesen zu sein es gibt da dieses
berühmtes beispiel der fledermaus das us
amerikanischen philosophen thomas niggl
der gesagt hat wie ist es eigentlich so
eine fledermaus zu sein gesicht mit
echolot im rahmen zu bewegen
diesen körper zu haben sich so und so
fortzupflanzen so zu kommunizieren
das scheint doch irgendwie ein bedürfnis
zu sein wenn man davon ausgeht das ist
nicht nur bloßes verhalten kein automat
so eine fledermaus ersten lebewesen mit
gefühlen mit ja mit bewusstsein
letztlich ja ich würde daher völlig
zustimmen nur gerade beim thema bewusst
sein dass also so viele nicht nur
philosophen sondern auch kombinations
wissenschaftler in wallung versetzt
da wäre ich sehr dafür den ball flach zu
halten
also erstmal wie fühlt es sich an eine
fledermaus zu sein
ich glaube nicht dass das eine gute
frage ist oder wenn die wenn ist eine
gute frage ist dann würde ich sagen wie
fühlt es sich an eine fledermaus zu sein
gar nicht es gibt kein hintergrund
gefühl dass das fledermaus seien ständig
begleiter kann man sagen wie viel das
ich für eine fledermaus an eine mücke zu
essen
das ist halte ich für eine sehr viel
bessere frage und ich denke dass die
antwort oft lautet schmackhaft das kann
man daraus ableiten dass a natürlich
diese mücke für die verdauung der
fledermaus geeignet ist das b ihr
geschmackssinn auf mücken eingerichtet
ist das ic dann zum beispiel auf führt
weiter nach beute zu suchen und es gibt
natürlich auch bestimmte ausdrücke nicht
nur im verhalten sondern auch in den
ausdrücken und in der haltung von
fledermäusen
das ist bei fledermäusen für uns
menschen relativ schwierig festzustellen
aber wenn es zu kunden oder
menschenaffen kommt haben wir überhaupt
kein problem festzustellen dass dem
schimpansen zum beispiel die traube
schmeckt und dass ihm die traube besser
schmeckt als die gurke machen ein gemüse
auf das glaube ich noch zu sprechen
kommen werden und da würde ich sagen
selbstverständlich besitzen fledermäuse
so was wie empfindung wie wahrnehmung
und wir können diese wahrnehmungen und
diese empfindungen dadurch verstehen
dass wir feststellen
aber was für sinnesorgane verfügen sie
über was für ein gehirn wie können sie
sich verhalten und auch wie gesagt den
zugang über die art und weise wie sie
uns anschauen
ja ich meine das ist ja bei diesem
kranken so erstaunlich also dass der hut
hat ganz andere sinnesorgane als wir das
haben ganz anderen aufbau des körpers im
gegensatz zu einem hund oder zu einem
menschenaffen wo wir eher das gefühl
haben ungefähren eine vorstellung wie
das ist und auch interessant finde ich
wenn man schaut auf den stammbaum der
evolution ist sind diese kranken ganz
früh schon auf einen anderen gast
gegangen als wir dann und trotzdem haben
sie eine ähnliche intelligenz
ausgebildet warum denn
ja also ich möchte erstmal die frage
erörtern inwiefern diese intelligenz
ähnlich ist es handle sich zweifellos um
eine hohe form von intelligenz aber sie
ist natürlich in verschiedener hinsicht
doch von der unseren sehr verschieden
denn die krake hat zum beispiel zwei
drittel ihrer nervenzellen in den
tentakeln die denkt sozusagen mit den
händen also nervenzellen neuronen die
wir im gehirn haben haben die in den
zentral zwei drittel davon ja und diese
neuronen in den tentakeln die nehmen
auch unabhängig von der zentrale war und
die bewegen auch die tentakel unabhängig
von der zentrale also wie gesagt wir
denken mit den händen das ist die form
von taktiler oder man tut motorischer
intelligenz in die ich bei mir selbst im
alltag oft schmerzlich vermisse die aber
zum beispiel klavierspieler haben wo sie
sie haben das richtige tut aber der
geist gar nicht dabei ist das ist völlig
richtig nur die klavierspieler tun das
weil sie eben mit dem zentralen
unser system besonders gut vernetzt sind
ja es gibt keine neuronen in der hand
die jetzt bei der apassionata die fäden
zieht
das ist ein unterschied und ich glaube
insofern ist es schon richtig war es
über die geraten oft gesagt wird sie
sind das plausibelste beispiel für einen
intelligenten alien auf das während auf
diesem planeten stoßen können also
dieses ganze fremde wie würden sie
intelligenz überhaupt definieren wie ist
das definiert ja gut man wirklich noch
eine abgedroschene definition von
intelligenz wonach intelligenz einfach
das ist was der test misst ja
intelligenz das ist ja genau nun das
halte ich nicht für besonders
zielführend allzumal wenn wir von tieren
handeln weil ein normaler intelligenz
test hat auch immer eine sprachliche
komponente und die ist natürlich auf die
also zumindest allermeisten tiere
überhaupt nicht anwendbar
ich würde intelligenz er definieren als
die fähigkeit auch ganz neuartige
probleme flexibel zu lösen und zwar
nicht nur durch konditionierung sondern
zumindest auch durch versuch und irrtum
und durch den versuch die zugrunde
liegenden mechanismen zu verstehen
okay es ist ja so dieses flexible
kreative problemlösung verhalten das
findet man bei einigen tieren etwa auch
bei haben zum beispiel die dann
irgendwie sogar ein werkzeug gebrauchen
um an ein gutes stück zu kommen kommen
und wir schauen uns dazu machen kurzen
beitragen
man sieht ja hat zwei erste zur
verfügung muss diese was nicht eine made
oder dieses stück unterkriegen und als
meine zweijährige tochter würde
glücklich schätzen in diesem versucht
habe ich mal sehen was schafft das war
der falsche doch das greift darin er
damit weiter weg sie diene rahmen ist
ganz schön beeindruckend also diese
fertigkeit auch noch mal die will nicht
warum nur
ja ganz schön beeindruckend
ach ja ich denke dass wir hier gesehen
haben dass eine traditionelle
vorstellung zu einem allein
erkennungsmerkmal des menschen nicht
stimmt also wir sind nicht die einzigen
die werkzeuge gebrauchen oder auch nur
herstellen
das hat jane goodall schon 1961
festgestellt die hat entdeckt dass
schimpansen sich zweige abbrechen und
die dann auch zu recht richten und mit
ihnen nach termiten fischen zu können
und daraufhin hat ihr damaliger
arbeitgeber leakey gesagt jetzt müssen
wir entweder den begriff des werkzeugs
umdefinieren oder den begriff des
menschen oder müssen zugestehen dass
schimpansen auch menschen sind weil sie
nämlich diese angebliche nur den
menschen zu kommen der fähigkeit
besitzen
und dann war klagen wie der
werkzeuggebrauch ist nicht das was uns
menschlich macht noch nicht mal die
produktion von werkzeugen
denn da gibt es also auch noch ganz
viele beeindruckende beispiele wie tiere
zum teil gegenstände so manipulieren
damit sie über diese gegenstände seien
andere gegenstände manipulieren können
[Musik]
ich möchte noch mal ganz vorne anfangen
also bei dieser krake oder bei der
fledermaus und der frage wie fühlt es
sich an so ein wesen zu sein was erleben
diese tiere da gibt es auch weniger
komplexe tiras nehmen wir eine amöbe
oder eine ameise oder einen wurm wo man
sich diese frage natürlich auch stellen
kann und dann fragt sich gibt's
irgendeine an grad von komplexität wo
plötzlich das licht angeht im innern
dieses wesens und und das schmerzen
empfindet zum beispiel oder etwas
bewusst erlebt eine pflanze würde man ja
sagen vermutlich eher nicht
ja das ist eine wirklich ausgesprochen
schwierige frage das ist auch eine frage
die mich an diesem ganzen themenkomplex
fasziniert also wenn man vom geist der
tiere spricht dann kommt man schnell zu
so einem zu so einer art hippen effekt
ja entweder man gesteht ihnen gar nichts
zu dann müsste man zum schluss sagen ach
ja auch schimpansen können nicht
wahrnehmen
auch schimpansen denn sie können nicht
denken dass da eine banane ist auch
schimpansen können kein schmerzempfinden
also diese position gibt es tatsächlich
auch heute noch verweigert ja sicherlich
zb robert brandl und peter sellers die
haben solche positionen vertreten
auf der anderen seite gibt es dann auch
die die die wippe kann auch umkippen ja
wenn man sagt aber selbstverständlich
können schimpansen denken können
wahrnehmen
aber wenn schimpansen warum dann nicht
auch runter wenn die hunde warum dann
nicht auch kraken wenn fragen warum ich
auch quallen den qualm warum nicht alle
mögen also also wo zieht man die grenze
was ist dass sie kann die grenze
ja und da würde ich immer noch im geiste
wittgensteins sagen es gibt keine
scharfe grenze und die frage wann das
lied
dann geht das ist kein digitales
phänomen es ist nicht so dass plötzlich
der schalter umgelegt wird sondern ich
denke es gibt so eine graduelle
verschiebung von dem bloßen empfinden
von schädlichen reizen zum empfinden von
schmerzen und die können wir zum teil
daran festmachen dass bestimmte tiere
komplexere tiere nicht nur auf eine
bestimmte art und weise reagieren
sondern in ihrer ganzen befindlichkeit
auch betroffen sind ja zum beispiel
selbst bei der krake die jetzt ein
wunderbares beispiel ist aber weil sie
so fremd ist in vielerlei beziehung hat
man ja gesehen nachdem der hier einen
halben tentakel abgebissen hat und sie
also nur um haaresbreite mit dem leben
davon kam hat sie sich zurückgezogen in
ihr schlupfloch die farbe hat sich
völlig verändert sie war völlig
apathisch ja und dann können sie sagen
also das ist dann halt nichts mehr was
man jetzt mit der unmittelbaren reaktion
auf den hai in verbindung bringen könnte
sondern der umstand dass sie schwer
verletzt worden ist der den empfindet
sie offensichtlich auch eine bestimmte
weise die die ihre ganze beziehung zur
umwelt verändert und das ist wie gesagt
ganz unabhängig von den anzeichen die
wir bei wirbeltieren besonders bei
säugetieren für schmerzen haben und die
natürlich auch ganz vielfältig
wissenschaftlich belegt sind
aber es schon interessant die frage ob
es nur eine reaktion auf einen reiz ist
oder ob irgendwie was sozusagen mehr
damit einher geht ein denken einen
wollen ein entscheiden sogar als bei
ameisen fand ich das so interessant zu
erfahren dass die wenn der ameise tot
ist wird die aus dem ameisen nest
getragen
ich habe dann haben einige gedacht war
die haben ein verständnis für tod und
für endlichkeit und so weiter aber dann
hat man glaube ich herausgefunden dass
ist nur weil die in so eine säure
absondern
und man kann auch eine lebendige ameisen
mit dieser säure bestreichen sie wird
als nächstes wird genauso ausgeschafft
ja dass ich deswegen ist das sicherlich
kein beleg dafür dass ameisen einen
begriff vom tod haben
allerdings wenn dann so dinge vorkommen
wie zum beispiel trauer schmerz
bezüglich des verlusts dann würde man
eher davon sprechen dass hier ein
verständnis von toad for liegt bei
welchen tieren bürger ja gut ein
oft gewähltes beispiel das meer nicht so
glücklich scheint ist dass viele
menschen affen mütter ihre toten kinder
lange mit sich tragen und die also schon
fast halb verwest sein wissen wie sie
sie endlich fahren lassen und dass die
gruppe dieses verhalten das sie sonst
nicht tolerieren würde in dem fall
toleriert aber in mir scheint das kein
besonders gutes beispiel zu sein denn
irgendwie das muttertier verhält sich ja
hier in einer weise die er andeutet dass
sie nicht gemerkt hat dass dieses kind
von ihr jetzt für immer verloren ist ja
das ist dass es nicht mehr zum leben
zurück kommt also für eine
einverständnis der trennungslinie
zwischen dem was lebt und dem was
endgültig tot ist taugt das meines
erachtens nicht aber beeindruckender ist
das zum beispiel elefanten alljährlich
stätten besuchen auf denen sich gebeine
von gruppen von verstorbenen
gruppenmitgliedern befinden ja so
interessant die mit ihren rüsseln das
ist ihre tentakel der für sie auch viel
wichtiger ist als wir uns die nase mit
dem betrachten sie dann diese diese
gebeine wissen diese elefant nach dass
die selbst irgendwann sterben werden das
wage ich zu bezweifeln bei elefanten
also eines ist ganz klar tiere können
todesängste ausstehen also wenn sie
unmittelbar bedroht werden also schweine
die server zur schlachtung getrieben
werden
die sind in todesangst ob die schweine
dann wenn sie in der absperrung der
biobäuerin fröhlich nach nach was graben
ob die dann an ihren zukünftigen tod
denken das wage ich zu bezweifeln
ja also es besteht ja ein unterschied
zwischen todesangst und dem wissen um
den eigenen tod
und dafür gibt es soweit ich weiss nur
anekdotische belegschaft wieder
schwierig wie man das am verhalten
zeigen zeigen möchte oder was ja nicht
man kann es ja nicht fragen die tiere
absolut und es ist glaube ich kein
zufall dass der interessanteste beleg
für ein wissen um die eigene
sterblichkeit von einem thriller namens
coco stammt rot grün grüner weibchen
namens coco stammt die zeichensprache
gelernt hat und so lautet die anekdote
man hat sie gefragt wohin gehen tiere
wenn sie tot sind und er hat dann gesagt
per zeichensprache ein bequemes loch und
dann hat er eine geistige macht die so
nach abschiedskuss aussieht da könnte
man sagen wenn das verheben wird ja dann
könnte man vielleicht sagen dass hier
coco auch ein bewusstsein davon
manifestiert dass es mit der selber auch
zu ende gehen wird
wir müssen das ein bisschen erläutern
lassen sie uns da bleiben bei dieser
sprache es gibt nämlich noch einen
anderen auf einem zwerg schimpansen und
bonobo namens kennt sie ich glaube das
war der erste menschenaffe der dann auch
eine sprache gelernt hat also der
versteht englisch kann man sagen 5000
wörter kann selbst mit den sohn einer
symbolsprache
auf dem tippen kann glaube ich 500
zeichnen oder wird da irgendwie
artikulieren wie kam es eigentlich dass
du dass diese auf das gelernt hat ja
also kein see ist natürlich ein ein
musterschüler von david rambo die sich
sehr um ihn bemüht hat und er hat so
jedenfalls die kolportierte geschichte
das von selbst erlernt als er den
vergeblichen versuchen seiner mutter das
beizubringen zugeschaut hat und diese
lexie grey sind insofern sehr
interessant die haben keinerlei visuelle
ähnlichkeit mit dem was sie bezeichnen
die sind also sowie menschliche wörter
nicht über eine ähnlichkeit mit dem
verbunden was sie bezeichnen sondern
durch das was man vielleicht
konventionen also das zeichen für einen
baum sieht nicht aus wie ein baum
sondern wie irgendwas anderes sieht nach
vielleicht wenn ich mir jetzt baum
vorstellen könnte ich mir vielleicht
gerade noch vorstellen als sieht aus wie
ein skistiefel dem man so aber ja also
es besteht jedenfalls keine visuellen
visuelle ähnlichkeit es handelt sich
hier nicht um das was man ikonische
zeichen nennt also die chronische
zeichen zum beispiel das flucht signal
dass hier wie in jedem studio angebracht
ist dank besteht schon eine ikonische
ähnlichkeit zwischen der brennenden
figur die abgebildet ist und der
tätigkeit die hier angedeutet wird aber
das ist bei menschen eher die ausnahme
die meisten unserer zeichen sind mit dem
was sie bezeichnen mehr oder weniger
willkürlich verbunden das ist schon
interessant es gibt auch andere tiere
oder etwa ein border collie namens rico
der irgendwie mehrere wörter konnte dann
ein graupapagei namens aleks
nach delfine habe ich gelesen geben sich
selbst nahmen also rufen sich beim namen
können tiere das lernen solche sprach
ich meine dieser kann zieht er wurde ja
mit menschen aufgezogen natürlich andere
bonobos die einfach irgendwie im urwald
sind natürlichen habitat lernen das
natürlich nicht aber das potenzial
scheint da zu sein
das ist richtig aber wenn man wir haben
ja auch das potenzial zum mond zu
fliegen ja deswegen würde man trotzdem
nicht sagen dass eine raumfahrt zum mond
so zum allgemeinen menschlichen natur
gehört viel er gehört zu unserer natur
dass wir die art von technologie
entwickeln können uns das ermöglicht
also ich finde den vergleich mit bonobo
sind freier wildbahn schon interessant
denn die können natürlich keine
lexikalische sprache aber sie
verständigen sich verständigen sich
schon mittels gesten und mittels lauten
und das repertoire ist aber gerade was
die laute an beschrieben anbelangt
relativ beschränkt also dass die
ausdrucksmöglichkeiten sind sehr
beschränkt aber das ist ja bei den
meisten tieren so glaube ich sie
kommunizieren sehr feinsinnig feinfühlig
aber wahrscheinlich würden sie nicht
sagen dass tiere eine sprach ja also
nehmen wir mal die delfine die
kommunizieren insofern sehr fein gerade
ich als sie ihre identität über diese
signale kundtun ja also sie zeigen sich
wechselseitig wer jetzt hier an
geschwungen kommt aber ob die in der
freien wildbahn damit irgendwelche
sachverhalte ausdrücken dass es
überhaupt nicht gesagt ja was bei den
meisten tieren fehlt also um es mal ganz
milde zu sagen ist das was linguistin
besonders bewegt nämlich die syntax also
in menschlichen sprachen
da haben wir eine beschränkte anzahl von
elementen nennen wir es immer
wörter die können wir aber gemäss von
regeln zu einer unbeschränkten anzahl
von kombinationen verknüpfen ja wir
können aus einem beschränkten lexikon
wie man das nennt eine unbeschränkte
anzahl von sätzen bilden und diese sätze
unterscheiden sich in ihrer bedeutung
also maria küsst roberta hat eine andere
bedeutung als roberta küsst maria hatte
eine andere bedeutung als roberta sieht
maria und wir können das dann auch noch
modifizieren maria küsst roberta
leidenschaft ich im garten um
mitternacht etc und diese möglichkeit
eine unbeschränkte anzahl von sätzen zu
bilden die finden wir bei keinem
nichtmenschlichen tier
[Musik]
obwohl wenn ich irgendwie jetzt seit
einigen wochen hört man wieder die vögel
zwitschern morgen früh wenn man das
fenster aufmacht das ist keine sprache
wo die ziemlich komplex ist daraus
unterschiedlichen mustern besteht das
ist ein interessanter fall vögel die
schneiden was so diese syntaktischen
fähigkeiten anbelangt also die fähigkeit
elemente zu kombinieren sehr gut ab aber
ich glaube nicht dass es hinweise darauf
gibt dass sie dadurch auch
unterschiedliche sachverhalte ausdrücken
die annoncieren wiederum ihre identität
oder sie locken zum beispiel
geschlechtspartner an
aber es ist nicht so dass sie sich
dadurch informationen über das
vermitteln was vorgeht mit der ausnahme
von bestimmten warnrufen zum beispiel da
kann man das feststellen es gibt auch
als beispiel von tieren ich weiß nicht
ob das ehrt menschen sind die
unterschiedliche berufe haben für
unterschiedliche feinde die kommen ja
dass ihr das auto ja das wäre dann so
eine form von von kommunikation wo man
sozusagen sachverhalt nämlich achtung
ein adler greift und kommuniziert das
ist völlig richtig also das hat man zum
beispiel hier in zug der erdmännchen
nachgewiesen aber schon früher
wusste man das von grünen meerkatzen
also es gibt einen beruf für leoparden
einen anderen für adler einen dritten
für schlangen und nicht nur produzieren
diese meerkatzen diese warnrufe
sozusagen mit der absicht andere zu
warnen sondern die anderen reagieren
dann auch auf die warnrufe gemäß der
situation also die warnrufe beziehen
sich auf eine bestimmte situation
leopard sich aber auch die empfänger des
signals reagieren dann auf bestimmte
weise bei leoparden steigen sie auf
einen baum bei adlern verstecken sie
sich in einem busch bei schlangen
richten sie sich auf uns schauen im gras
wo denn die die schlange ist und die
möglichkeit der täuschung gibt es dann
natürlich auch jawohl dieses täuschende
signalisieren das ist nicht besonders
gut erforscht es gibt viele anekdoten
aber es gibt auch zb unter pavianen
beispiele dafür dass exemplare die von
einem stärkeren exemplar verfolgt werden
dann einen warnruf ausstoßen das der
verfolger schaut welche gefahr her
lautet lauert und dann verschwindet der
flüchtling aber es ist nicht besonders
gut erforscht und vor allem muss man da
aufpassen
es lässt sich aus diesen befunden
alleine nicht ableiten dass das
flüchtende tier sich denkt dass
alpha-männchen möchte mich verprügeln
das alphamännchen weiß wo ich hin renne
ich habe jetzt die möglichkeit dass
alpha-männchen abzulenken indem ich er
seine aufmerksamkeit auf etwas anderes
richte
das ist wieder diese sprechblasen konnte
das wäre eine überinterpretation würden
sie sehr oder vermenschlichung was da
war sie zu viel zugemutet also das was
ich meine die die sprech- oder denkt
blasen konzeption genannt habe ist
meines erachtens eine vermenschlichung
von tier weil sozusagen man kann dieses
verhalten nach einfachheit
absolut also was er gelernt hat wenn er
diesen schrei ausstößt dann dreht sich
darum genau so kann ich also ich würde
das mal für mich am akkurates und
beschreiben was sich daraus ergibt ist
dass dieses exemplar der das flüchtende
exemplar gelernt hat dass es diese
möglichkeit gibt andere abzulenken
ok und dass dabei würde ich zunächst mal
belassen natürlich hier müsste man
wirklich noch weitere versuche machen es
ist nur sehr schwer solche versuche in
der wildbahn durchzuführen wobei wir
immer besser darin werden aber ich meine
diese fähigkeit sich in andere
hineinzuversetzen
die zeichnet uns menschen ja irgendwie
heraus aber es gibt doch hinweise dass
das bei tieren auch da ist also das gibt
sicher versuche die das zeigen so zu
sagen dass man wie die position ändert
und sozusagen kurz in die andere rolle
schlüpft um dann eine aktion auszuführen
es gibt bei tieren nachgewiesenermaßen
das was man im party nennt oder auch
emotional konnten dass nämlich die
emotionen und gefühle eines gegenübers
sich einem selber aufs gemüt schlagen
wie man sagen könnte oder auch das kann
man sehr schön bei menschenaffen zeigen
die der umstand dass gähnen ansteckend
ist
ich hoffe dass wir jetzt hier die
zuschauer wenn nicht müssen sich vor zu
haben dass das übertragbar ist aber die
der bloße umstand dass es sozusagen
diese nennt das ja auch konnten das ist
also wie eine stadt wie eine ansteckung
das beinhaltet natürlich noch nicht das
sich explizit ideen darüber habe was im
anderen vor sich geht aber gibt es nicht
auch versuche oder irgendwie
beobachtungen die zeigen dass vögel
futter vergraben und bemerkten dass sie
beobachtet werden von anderen vögeln und
so baut der andere weg ist
nehmen sie das futter wieder raus und
und vergraben es an einer anderen stelle
das ist eine der vielen wunderbaren
dinge die krähen tun können und
wiederum kann man sagen die krähen
wissen was wo andere hinschauen ja dass
also die die wissen wo andere hinschauen
daraus folgt noch nicht dass sie wissen
was andere sehen nun gibt es auch
relativ ausgeklügelte versuche die
zeigen sollen dass die das bei
schimpansen und ist auch klar ist nicht
nur wo die hinschauen sondern auch was
sie sehen oder gesehen haben
da arbeitet man dann mit verdeckung ja
also ich obwohl duell in dem moment das
nicht sehen kannst
weiß ich was du vorher gesehen hast und
deswegen wie verhalte ich mich auf
andere weise
ich denke dass da für mich ist das
überzeugend an aber auch da gibt es noch
skeptiker die sagen
auch schimpansen wissen zwar wo art
genossen hinschauen das ist ja
beobachtbar aber sie wissen deswegen
noch nicht was andere sehen oder gesehen
haben
aber wie gesagt ich bin in der beziehung
kulant ich würde sagen es gibt hinweise
nicht nur dafür dass menschenaffen zum
beispiel wissen was andere sehen es gibt
auch hinweise dafür dass sie verstehen
dass andere falsche überzeugungen haben
es gibt bei menschen diese berühmten
fotos beliefert hast also wenn wann
entwickeln
menschliche kinder die fähigkeit
festzustellen dass das was sie wissen
sich von dem unterscheiden kann was
andere glauben ja dann gibt's dieses
berühmte hütchenspiel
ja genau also wenn zum beispiel ein kind
schaut zu wie eine schokolade unter
einem becher versteckt wird ja und
sondern wer ihn max so heißt es im
ursprünglichen versuch max sieht dass
die schokolade links versteckt wurde
dann verlässt max das zimmer und
die versuche also die experimentatoren
oder jemand anderes nimmt die
schokoladen tut sie ihn unter die rechte
an den rechten becher und dann wird die
kind gefragt wenn maxit wieder
zurückkommt wo wird er nach der
schokolade suchen ja und bis ungefähr im
alter von vier jahren sagen sie er wird
im linken becher suchen denn angeles
ich bin jetzt ich bin auch für unter
vier jahren
er wird im rechtenbacher suchen denn die
kinder wissen ja da ist vital schokolade
tatsächlich und erst ab 4
sagen sie dann ja max wird unter dem
linken becher suchen weil er
fälschlicherweise der überzeugung ist
dass die schokolade unter dem linken
becher ist diesen versuch kann man die
tiere nicht machen weil man sich nicht
fragen kann so ist es man kann aber
sogenannte implizite falls believe tasks
mit ihnen durch und man kann zum
beispiel untersuchen wenn max jetzt
wieder reinkommt oder ein artgenosse
wieder reinkommt schauen sie dann um zu
antizipieren wohin sich dieser art
genosse wenden wird schauen sie dann auf
den becher unter dem das futter stück
ist oder schauen sie auf den becher
unter dem der artgenosse das futter
stück zuletzt gesehen hat und da lässt
sich feststellen
sie schauen tendenziell eher auf den
becher unter dem der artgenosse das
futter stück zuletzt gesehen hat war sie
sind auch offensichtlich überrascht sie
schauen viel länger hin wenn der
artgenosse plötzlich doch zum rechten
becher geht und diese tests sind jetzt
will ich doch ziemlich ausgeklügelt und
für mich deuten die anders zumindest
schimpansen und also andere
menschenaffen was das verständnis von
dem unterschied zwischen dem was jemand
glaubt und dem was jemand weiß so
ungefähr mit vierjährigen vergleichbar
sind ich meine diese fähigkeit dieser
ganz zentrale auch für die moral dass
man sich in andere hineinversetzen kann
ist eine weitere frage natürlich gibt es
so etwas wie moral bei tieren oder
altruismus und auch da gibt es viele
studien dazu vielleicht können sie kurz
sagen was du die wichtigsten
erkenntnisse sind also man weiß seit
langem dass es altruistisches verhalten
bei tieren gibt also ein exemplar
vollzieht eine handlung die ihm selber
nicht nützt aber einem artgenossen
nun ist es aber so dass diese
altruistischen verhaltensweisen sich
zumindest im allgemeinen auf zwei fälle
beschränken nämlich wenn es sich um den
sozusagen den den empfänger der wohltat
wenn es sich dabei um einen verwandten
handelt das nennt man kennt ships races
oder verwandtschaft altruismus bei
menschen würde man das vielleicht auch
nepotismus nennen ja also wir als
theoretischen gründen favorisieren wir
unsere verwandten in bestimmten
verhaltensweisen das ist also kein chip
adressen hat mit dem moralisch
aufgeladenen begriff von altruismus
nichts zu tun also unter menschen gilt
das manchmal auch als verwerflich also
nepotismus ist nichts was wir besonders
schätzen weil das parteiisch ist
natürlich natürlich also wir nicht etwa
weil es ist ein individuum besonders
verdient hat sondern ganz einfach weil
er mike stanley ist ja aber trotzdem
also es ist selbstlos in der hinsicht
dass man nicht jetzt gerade etwas
zurückbekommt von diesem individuum
sondern man hilft ihm einfach das ist
richtig der die andere form von
altruismus die auch also sehr
dokumentiert ist dieser reziproke
altruismus also dieses ist wie du mir so
ich dir
ich traue dich und erwartet dann dass du
mich auch mal irgendwann mal grau ist
also diese scheiß auf dem jahr
diese zwei formen von von
altruismus hat man nachgewiesen was man
nicht so sehr nach gewesen hat ist ein
altruismus aus motiven heraus die jetzt
nun wirklich nur daraus entstehen dass
man sagt das tut dem anderen gut ein
interessantes experiment das ziemlich
eindrücklich ist wurde mit
kapuzineraffen gemacht und zwar vom
niederländischen primatenforscher frans
de waal und das so zeigen dass tiere
sogar so etwas wie ein
gerechtigkeitsempfinden haben wir schon
mal kurz ein
wir sehen hier zwei kapuzineraffen in
getrennten käfigen und die haben eine
aufgabe zu erfüllen nämlich die müssen
einen stein nehmen von der versuchs
leiterin und den wieder nach draußen
geben und kriegen dann eine belohnung
nur kriegen die nicht dieselbe belohnung
also der affe links bekommt jeweils eine
gurke als belohnung und gurken schmecken
für diese offen
wie man sieht leider nicht so gut wie
trauben und der auf rechts bekommt
trauben und da kann es kaum glauben
der linke kapuzineraffen und er testet
das jetzt noch mal macht nochmal diese
aufgabe bescheid aber was falsch gemacht
hat testet den stein sogar an einer wand
gibt ein wieder nach draußen und ist
gespannt und wieder nur eine gurke und
jetzt bringt er natürlich durch
also unglaublich eindrücklich echt zum
protest gegen unfaires behandelt werden
im jahr das ist so ein bisschen wie die
wall street wall street bewegung was
diese versuchsanordnung schön zeigt ist
dass es bei diesen kapuzineraffen eine
abneigung gegen ungleichbehandlung gibt
nun würden manche sagen das zeigt dass
die einen sinn für fairness oder einen
sinn für gerechtigkeit haben
das zeigt jetzt diese versuchsanordnung
nicht warum nicht weil die abneigung die
dort manifestiert wird von dem exemplar
auf der linken seite die ist ja
egozentrisch ich ärgerte mich
entsetzlich darüber dass ich weniger
bekommen als der andere
aber wenn der andere weniger bekommt als
ich dann juckt mich das überhaupt nicht
das kennen wir ja auch beim menschen
es gibt leute die wegen sich
fürchterlich auf wenn ihnen die rente
nicht ausbezahlt wird aber nicht so sehr
wenn anderen die rente nicht ausbezahlt
aber menschliche gemeinschaften sind
meines erachtens nur möglich weil wir
auch anderen gegenüber einen sinn für
fairness haben und gibt es versuche bei
tieren wo dann hat es ja genau dieser
bevor versuchsanordnung der käfig ist
etwas größer weil wir haben es mit
schimpansen zu tun und da gibt es
versuche die belegen sollen dass unter
schimpansen oft das bevorzugte exemplar
auf der rechten seite die traube nicht
ist wenn das benachteiligt der exemplar
auf der linken seite nur gruppen bekommt
schimpansen bei schimpansen
jetzt sind diese befunde ich würde sagen
nicht völlig überzeugend aber es besteht
wohl schon hier eine tendenz und man
kann hier durchaus von wurzeln des
menschlichen altruismus und der
menschlichen ablehnung von einer
ungleichheit sprechen die ist nämlich
nicht nur egozentrisch sondern
wie man in der fachsprache sagt hallo
zentrische die richtet sich auch auf
andere das ist schon interessant also
wir finden bei gewissen tieren das ganze
spektrum von rein schmerzempfinden über
kreative problemlösungskompetenz über
werkzeuggebrauch sogar perspektiven
übernahme bis zu diesem fernes empfinden
bis zu echten tourismus
die frage ist jetzt was folgt daraus für
unsere parks ist für unser verhalten
unseren umgang mit tieren hat diese
diese disziplin in der sie unterwegs
sind sozusagen den geist der tiere zu
untersuchen irgendwelche folgen oder
konsequenzen für unser handeln
das denke ich schon also die
offensichtlichsten konsequenzen sind
natürlich ethischer natur
sie betreffen die art und weise wie wir
tiere behandeln
allerdings ist der zusammenhang nicht
ganz einfach es gibt in der
moralphilosophie eine position die nennt
sich kontrakt realismus der zufolge
beruht die moral auf einem vielleicht
nicht explizit ausgesprochenen vertrag
zwischen gleichwertigen also moralische
verpflichtungen gegenüber hab ich nur
weil wir sozusagen teil einer
gemeinschaft sind die durch einen
impliziten vertrag sich wechselseitig
verpflichtet fühlt wenn der kontrakt
tourismus richtig wäre dann hätten wir
moralische verantwortung nur gegenüber
denjenigen tieren die selber auch uns
moralisch behandeln
ja und dann würde daraus zum beispiel
folgende ich ja wir haben moralische
verpflichtung gegen schimpansen aber
nicht gegenüber kapuzineraffen nachricht
gegenüber schweinen und kühen und so
genau
ich halte den kontrakt tourismus für
falsch und ich denke wir müssen streng
unterscheiden zwischen der frage ob
tiere subjekt der moralischen denken
sind ja das also selber moralische
urteile und moralische einstellungen
haben
objekten moralischen denkens also den
wir etwas schulden und da denke ich sind
die implikationen genauso wichtig aber
weniger einfach aber nehmen wir zum
beispiel mal
wir haben die kapuzineräffchen die haben
also nur egozentrische abneigung
gegenüber ungleichheit aber diese
egozentrische ablehnung müssen wir
natürlich respektieren ja also für mich
ist dieses experiment selbst wird es
kein moralisches denken
auf seiten der kapuzineraffen nachweist
ein argument dafür kapuzineraffen fair
zu behandeln also in nicht für gleiche
leistung unterschiedliche belohnungen zu
verabreichen
das wäre für mich also eine eine
schlussfolgerung und man sieht sehr
schön hier wir hier bestimmte moral
philosophische überlegungen mit
bestimmten einsichten in die fähigkeiten
und aber auch grenzen von von tieren
einhergehen ich meine es gibt noch eine
berühmte position des philosophen jeremy
bentham der der gesagt hat es überhaupt
nicht relevant ob tiere denken können
wie klug visieren für die frage wie wir
sie behandeln sondern sondern rein die
tatsache ob sie leiden können ob sie
schmerzen empfinden können also dann
wäre der zusammenhang sehr lose man
müsste gar nicht sozusagen ganz viel
herausfinden wie sie diese tiere und wie
klug sie sehen sondern man hat das sonst
schon grund genug sie moralisch
anständig zu haben ich denke das pensum
nur zum teil recht hat ja der umstand
dass die meisten tiere schmerzen
empfinden können der verpflichtet uns zu
einem bestimmten verhalten denn es ist
einfach unmoralisch ohne sehr guten
grund schmerzen zuzufügen
aber die frage ob tiere vielleicht auch
mehr können als nur schmerzen empfinden
ist trotzdem relevant wenn tiere zum
beispiel wie ich meine auch denken
können wenn sie absichten haben können
und wünsche und zwar nicht nur absichten
und wünsche dass hier und jetzt
betreffen sondern auch die zukunft
betreffend
dann haben wir auch eine verpflichtung
diese absichten und wünsche zu
respektieren
also es mag natürlich gründe geben um in
einer bestimmten situation über das
hinwegzugehen was ein haustier zum
beispiel will wenn man es zum beispiel
wäscht oder zum tierarzt bringt aber
dafür braucht man dann gründe
ansonsten wäre es vielleicht auch ganz
tiefer stufe aber wäre es ethisch falsch
ja tieren irgend etwas aufzuzwingen
denjenigen tieren die nicht nur
empfinden können sondern auch wünsche
und absichten haben und wenn und da
kommen wir wieder auf den tod zurück
dann kommt immer wieder auf sein tor
zurück
wenn jetzt tiere nicht nur wünsche und
absichten bezüglich der gegenwart oder
der mittelbaren zukunft haben sondern
auch für gesamtes leben was ist strittig
was ich für richtig halte dann würde das
bedeuten dass wir kein recht haben tiere
zu töten
selbst dann nicht wenn diese tötung
völlig schmerzlos erfolgen könnte also
wenn sozusagen ein menschenaffe pläne
für die zukunft seiner kinder hat dann
wäre es völlig unangemessen
auch das ist natürlich ein umstrittener
punkt da könnte man jetzt noch lange
debattieren ich möchte mit ihnen nochmal
zurück zum anfang oder zum titel dieser
sendung also tiere verstehen aber wie
das heißt die tiere verstehen ihre welt
aber die frage sein wie wir tiere
verstehen können und sie sind ein
grosser spezialist was wittgenstein
angeht den österreichischen philosophen
den sie schon erwähnt haben und von
wittgenstein gibt es ja den ziemlich
rätselhaft einsatz der lautet wenn ein
löwe sprechen könnte wir könnten ihn
nicht verstehen
vielleicht mögen sie diesen satz noch
erläutern wir ja ich glaube was wirklich
ein sicher nicht im sinne hatte ist ein
löwe der uns begegnet und der dann
vielleicht mit sehr rauer stimme von
sich gibt
ich hatte gerade in der antilope an dir
bin ich nicht interessiert sondern was
er im sinn hatte ist es gibt ja unter
löwen nun auch ausgeprägte
kommunikations mechanismen ob man sie
jetzt sprache nennt oder nicht er halte
ich für weniger wichtig und wenn wir
können diese kommunikationssysteme
feststellen wir können auch sehen dass
diese bestimmte signale das müssen nicht
die müssen nicht akustische natur sein
das kann auch körperhaltung sein oder
wo geht die löwen bei der jagd hin wo
geht der länge bei der jagd in der
schwanz wird er auf bestimmte weise
gewedelt
wir würden das auch dann nicht verstehen
wenn wir über diese signale bescheid
wüssten
ja weil uns die lebensform von löwen so
fremd ist
also wir wissen nicht warum er das tut
wir wissen genau wisse nicht warum er
das tut also ich glaube persönlich dass
hier mit gestein vielleicht auch dieser
denkt blasen konzeption zum opfer
gefallen ist
wir können keine denkweise schaffen aber
wir können doch über das was er jetzt
zum beispiel eine bestimmte schwanz
bewegung und bestimmte körperhaltung
oder auch eine bestimmte modulation
akustische modulation für die löwen oder
den möwen bedeuten
doch ich würde fast sagen beliebig viel
herausfinden
das ist übrigens eine der dinge die wir
in einem nationalen
forschungsschwerpunkt im moment
versuchen zu erreichen über die
revolution der der sprache genau wie es
dazu gekommen ist dass wir solche
komplizierten sätze bilden können diese
jetzt dahin schon von sich geben eine
letzte kurze frage wenn sie für eine
woche ein tier sein könnten herr glock
was wäre das für ein tier delfin
warum ich schwimme sehr gerne und sehr
schlecht wie die leute immer alles vz
bestätigen können aber ich würde gerne
besser schwimmen und delfine sind hoch
intelligent sie sind neugierig sie
schwimmen wunderbar nicht nur delfin und
ich würde mir das sehr interessant
vorstellen auf einen schwarm von fischen
zusammen mit dem gespann die jagd zu
machen dann können sie uns danach
berichten wie es ist ein sehr viel zu
sein oder eben nicht
ich glaube nicht sondern ich glaube man
muss sich klar machen was wir da heraus
finden ist nur wie wäre es für uns sich
in einer umgebung zu bewegen in der sich
tiere bewegen und ich glaube das ist
auch letztlich die botschaft von diesem
film ein lehrer der krake herr glock
vielen herzlichen dank für diesen
interessanten einblick in den geistert
ihre danke ich bedanke mich ja danke
ihnen fürs mitdenken bald ist es schon
zehn jahre her da wurden wir zeugen der
nuklearkatastrophe von fukushima welche
folgen dieses ereignis bis heute hat und
wie wir aus ethischer perspektive mit
risiken umgehen sollen darüber rede ich
nächste woche mit der philosophin und
physikerin rafaela hillerbrand und farsi
den film singen gegen lukaschenko noch
nicht gesehen haben dann bleiben sie
dran er nimmt sie mit nach belarussen
porträtierten freien kurs von minsk
dessen mitglieder immer wieder gegen das
repressive regime von lukaschenko
ansehen und dabei ihr leben riskieren
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]